- [Instructor] Before I go to a new place,
I try to do some thorough
research about it.
What do I want to do there?
What's the weather forecast?
What's the chance that it might erupt?
I learned this hard way recently.
While preparing for a trip to
Mount Rainier National Park,
I somehow missed that the mountain itself
is actually a volcano.
Though it hasn't erupted
in over a century,
it has the potential to do so again,
something that it would
have been nice to know
more than a week before
I left for my vacation.
Volcanoes are one of the
most dramatic examples
of a natural hazard,
a naturally occurring
phenomenon that can pose risks
to humans and society.
Natural hazards can be very dangerous
for our communities.
But scientists can help people
better understand the risks
that may occur where they live
so everyone can work together
to prepare safety guidelines.
Different places experience
different natural hazards
due to local geographic
or atmospheric conditions.
For example, a storm on open
plains could spawn a tornado.
Similarly, a storm over the ocean
could grow into a hurricane or a cyclone
by the time it reaches the coast.
These coastal rainstorms,
along with their colder
counterparts, blizzards,
are the main natural
hazards that I may run into
where I live in the mid-Atlantic.
Too much rain or snow can
be dangerous, of course,
but scientists have gotten pretty good
at predicting weather conditions.
Meteorologists use all
kinds of technologies
to map where and when a storm may form.
Orbiting satellites can take pictures
of cloud patterns from above.
Weather stations back on the surface
can use electromagnetic wave fields
measured through Doppler radar
to determine how heavy rain is falling
or how strong the wind is
blowing in those same clouds.
They feed all of this and
other data into computer models
that can help them predict
if the storm is severe enough
to become a natural hazard.
For example, this map
from the National Oceanic
and Atmospheric Administration's
Weather Prediction Center
shows where people can expect rainstorms,
where others can expect snowstorms,
and where those storms
may become powerful enough
to pose risks.
Despite great advances in our ability
to predict natural hazards,
there are some phenomena
that are less predictable,
which can make them harder to prepare for.
You see, the outer part
of Earth is made up
of large moving pieces
called tectonic plates.
These plates can grind or
slip against each other,
releasing energy in the
form of seismic waves.
Most of the time,
we don't even notice
these tectonic movements.
But especially along boundaries
or fault lines in the plates,
people may experience
the ground-shaking tremors of earthquakes.
Earthquakes can be especially dangerous
in highly populated areas
where they damage buildings, roads,
and other forms of human infrastructure.
Earthquakes are often associated
with volcanic activity,
since volcanoes are often
found near boundaries
and fault lines of the tectonic plates.
As the plates move and magma
swells up to the surface,
volcanic eruptions can release everything
from clouds of gas or ash
to rivers of molten lava.
An earthquake in one
location may even agitate
large bodies of water enough
to generate a tsunami,
a huge and powerful wave,
along the coastline in another.
Tsunamis can affect the local region
as well as regions far away.
Scientists can't predict
an intense earthquake,
volcanic eruption, or
tsunami as effectively
as they can a severe weather event.
But they are working to better understand
Earth's seismic activity
and when it poses a risk.
For example, they use
tools like seismographs
to determine when an
earthquake is happening
and its strength or magnitude.
Data from both minor and major tremors
may help scientists figure out the signs
that an earthquake is coming,
giving communities along
fault lines an early warning
to evacuate or brace themselves,
rather than simply
reacting to the aftermath.
Engineers can even use
the data they've recorded
from past earthquakes to design buildings
and other structures to
withstand the effects
of future ones.
Communicating what they've
learned may help places
that experience seismic natural hazards
to prepare far in advance,
further reducing the risks that they face.
Natural hazards can cause a lot of harm.
But scientists are learning more every day
about why they occur
and how communities can remain resilient.
For my trip, I studied up
on visiting a volcano zone
and was relieved to find
that there's been no signs
that Mount Rainier's
erupting any time soon.
The whole experience really
reinforced the importance
of being prepared.
Even if natural hazards aren't common
where you live or travel,
having a preparedness plan
can help you stay safe
in a scary situation.
These are just some examples
of how scientific
research benefits society.
Now, if you'll excuse me,
I'll be setting up an emergency kit
for the next time I lose
power during a storm.